I'm Way less sad on the road because of
saundra that's great because I get to
take someone that I [ __ ] love and we
get to hang out and we have fun and we
go eat and we've and for years I
couldn't I couldn't afford it I couldn't
do it and it sucked and you know what I
found myself hanging out with fans a lot
which is great but at the end of night
they go home yeah and then you go home
yeah I know I do thanks for [ __ ]
having some beers with us we'll see yeah
and you're like yeah and I walk home
like a sad man alone yeah and I would
you know I don't even hang out I fly out
my features but I don't even hang out
with them I like it because you hang out
with Billy or no not at all I mean I
never all the time no no after the shows
or before the shows I'll have a meal but
like during the day I don't do like
let's go see the sides I do that with
his features like sandy Dan so and I
yeah we are Candice Candice Thompson I
invited Billy to a spin class in the
city he declined they didn't make it
well here's what I do
so I'm a I'm a I'm a baseball nerd and I
love going to baseball games 90% of the
people that I hang out with and comedy
don't like sports ie love soccer
sure okay cuz we're going to those games
all the time Arsenal FC fan okay we won
Tottenham should we go to Arsenal we did
should we go to a game in a Bratz and
North yeah should we take a 19-hour
flight and go no so I travel I don't
like the way you [ __ ] you you you you
you you you you you you you [ __ ]
bully
Kojak police because he just got into
baseball this year and he slowly started
into it I'm not [ __ ] on you I'm
saying I'm saying this out of my own
insecurities I like sports most of my
friends don't really like it that much
in comedy huh it sucks for me cuz I go
to things alone his most comments are
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't want to go
so I go by myself
baseball games on the road uh-huh but
sonj like sports so he'll go to anything
yeah so that's what I loved that I was
like cuz I used to go on the road a
feature I didn't even know I go hey man
I'm a baseball guy I would love to take
you to a game tomorrow there's a 2 p.m.
game I'll pay for your tickets your [ __ ]
and hotdogs and your beer yeah would you
end over to get us empty would you like
to go yeah and without fail every time
no to go would you like to go I mean
yeah it's like an infomercial and they
won't and people said no to me could I
went to the one time I forgot [ __ ] up
for the baseball game where I should
have gone I was in the movie paul simon
pegg yeah yeah hi the simon simon pegg
invited me to a Padres game okay why I
just a Padres fan nobody just he's not
even a baseball they just wanted to go
were you in San Diego yeah you're
shooting the shooting in San Diego right
and he said let's go to the game yeah
I said no God no you said no to Simon
Pegg yeah at the time though I didn't
really know who knew he was you know he
was I didn't see Shaun of the Dead that
was only thing that was out like
literally one of my favorite movies yeah
I never saw genuinely yeah and it was an
Allison Jones casted it right so cheap I
read I read in front of her she's the
best in the business
yep I got the movie I went and then when
the movie came out was cut out of the
movie and I'm a huge fan of it now yeah
because it seems oh you know I'm a Star
Trek Fred had all of them it was great
he's so he's a great writer he's so good
right and every time I lay in bed I
sometimes think of him I do and I go
like in my head like why would you you
know you know you should get one of
those you should get him one of those
fat heads of Simon Pegg to put on the
seat would you is there anything that
you've done I've done that you regret
and you replay in your head like I
should have done that on my yeah yeah I
have a million yeah yeah I have one that
I could tell ya what you do oh please
please tell me it's hard though because
I kind of want to save the story save
the story
I hope don't I have something to say no
no don't save the story let you say it
but just tell the story please
it's very long that's why I don't want
to do it that's very very long it was a
bad mistake I made and
very very long
[Music]